[Musique]
étranger
Lake City le lac est la
chose merveilleuse en soi à voir
c'est le berceau du ski nautique
depuis le début des années 1900 que nous avons eu pendant
la période du 4 juillet festival de la journée du ski nautique
Mississippi
Wisconsin Minnesota
[Musique  ]
est
étrangère
[Musique]
en fait, quand ils l'ont vu, ils ont fait
demi-tour avec leur bateau et sont revenus de l'
eau,
ils ont vu un sonar gigantesque que vous savez
lire au fond du lac,
je sais qu'ils avaient un plongeur dans le lac
qui coulait  dans quelque chose qu'il ne
savait pas ce que c'était et qu'il ne voulait pas y
retourner,
c'était comme si j'étais surveillé ou
quelque chose comme quelque chose là-bas
me regardait,
de nombreuses tribus avaient peur de
la région dont elles parlaient  une
créature entre la taille d'un éléphant
et d'un rhinocéros ils parlaient d'un
serpent géant ressemblant à un serpent de 40 pieds
ma sœur était tombée des
skis nautiques elle avait peur que nous l'ayons
sortie de l'eau assez rapidement et elle
n'a pas  été dans l'eau depuis lors,
j'ai été sur cette eau plusieurs fois
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses étranges
j'ai été sur l'eau quand c'est
vraiment agité c'est difficile de voir dans
l'eau si tard dans la nuit  au crépuscule au
lever du soleil, vous pouvez voir des choses sortir
quelque chose qui a fait surface
[Musique]
qui faisait peut-être cinq ou six pieds de
vous savez dans le sens de la longueur et peut-être six ou
sept pouces qui est sorti de l'eau
et il a vu une créature hors de l'eau
à environ quatre  les pieds sont sortis pour attraper un
oiseau volant, il était tellement terrifié qu'il
a enlevé ses enfants et ils sont partis, ils ont
arrêté de pêcher parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas
être la prochaine chose que ce monstre est venu
après
juste à ce moment-là alors que je me faisais
jeter et j'étais fou  mort de peur
Ça doit être ça que je criais
Honnêtement, je ne me souviens pas exactement de ce que je
criais pour vous dire la vérité, la plupart
des gens qui l'ont vu en étaient terrifiés
mais je disais quelque chose comme
c'est gros c'est gros c'est sombre et  sortez-moi
de l'eau il y a des trucs bizarres là-bas il
y a des trucs bizarres dans le lac je
pouvais sentir sa peur qu'elle veuille
sortir de cette eau
très rapidement
c'est
Pepe
bien Pepe a une longue histoire remontant
au moins aux années 1600 avec le  les premiers
Amérindiens ici
depuis plus de 100 200 ans ont
vu ce monstre et selon de nombreux témoignages,
c'est une bête terrifiante, de nombreuses
tribus avaient peur de la région que
si quelqu'un disparaissait ou que quelqu'un ne
revenait pas, ils le blâmaient sur le monstre
dans  Lac Pepin, si quelqu'un mourait ou si des
membres de la tribu que vous connaissiez se noyaient, ils blâmaient
la créature, il a donc été envisagé
que vous devriez éviter le retard à toutes
les possibilités, car si vous ne le faisiez pas, vous
pourriez rencontrer cette créature et de nombreuses
tribus n'ont pris que leur  les canoës les plus solides
et les plus robustes sur le lac
parce qu'ils avaient tellement peur de ce qu'il
y avait en dessous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
les explorateurs amenaient toujours un
prêtre jésuite avec eux parce que c'était celui qui
savait lire et écrire à l'époque dans les
années 1600 1700
la personne moyenne, même la royauté, ne savait ni
lire ni écrire, alors elle envoyait des membres du clergé
pour documenter le voyage qu'ils faisaient sur le
lac Pépin au moment où le lac Pépin était
déjà trouvé et déjà nommé,
donc ils connaissaient le lac Pépin et la
notation dit que nous étions  sur le lac Pépin
aujourd'hui a vu une grande créature nager sur
le lac, nous ne savons pas ce que c'était
et dans les années 1800, ils l'
appelaient parfois un monstre marin un serpent de mer un
monstre marin une bête du lac même
un serpent Bête donc vous avez  pour regarder tous
ces termes différents de ce que ces
gens rencontraient,
je suis tombé sur le rapport de 1871 juste en faisant
des recherches et je suis tombé sur
la notation
qu'une paire de messieurs locaux dit avoir vu
quelque chose nager sur le lac ou le
monstre du lac, ils l'ont appelé plus grand que  un
rhinocéros mais plus petit qu'un éléphant
ce qui est intéressant à propos du lac Pepin et
du monstre Pepe, c'est qu'il n'était pas
inhabituel dans les années 1800 qu'il y ait des dizaines
de lacs, rivières et ruisseaux dans le Wisconsin
et le Minnesota qui avaient Légendes d'une
bête un monstre dans leurs lacs mais
ce qui est intéressant à propos de Pepe, c'est que
la plupart de ces autres lacs et rivières, les
créatures semblent s'être éteintes, le
rapport s'est en quelque sorte arrêté alors que Pepe
à partir des années 1970 a vraiment
refait surface dans les années 1970,
les rapports ont commencé à revenir de plus
en plus alors que  aujourd'hui, nous recevons
autant de rapports sur Pepe que
dans les années 1800 et j'ai parlé à
des gens qui disent ou jurent qu'ils ont
vu quelque chose d'inexplicable dans ce
lac,
beaucoup de vieilles clameurs
au tournant du  siècle a fait référence
à des incidents qui ont eu lieu dans le lac
qui étaient tout simplement inexplicables d'énormes
mouvements corporels énormes dans le lac du mouvement de l'eau
dans le lac qui n'auraient pas pu
se produire par des moyens normaux, nous recevons
beaucoup de questions sur Pepe
Pepe est tout à fait un  conte mon mari
a vu Pepe et a pris une photo de
Pepe
inexplica
[Musique]
c'est une opération étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique]
nous sommes à Lake City Minnesota [
Musique] Les
frontières du Canada vers notre nord notre ville
est divisée en deux comtés Comté de Wabasha
et  Comté de Goodyear, état du Minnesota,
nous sommes sur le fleuve Mississippi, qui
se trouve être à ce point particulier la
partie la plus large et la plus profonde du
fleuve Mississippi. Lake City est assez
unique, nous avons environ sept miles de
rivage public sur le lac où il est ouvert
au  public où vous pouvez aller et rester
là et pêcher Wade nager faire ce que vous
voulez et ou simplement vous asseoir et profiter du
paysage au bord de l'eau et euh beaucoup
de gens font ça et et c'est là que
beaucoup de gens voient voir beppy et nous avons
La station de surveillance de Pepe est installée, vous verrez
des panneaux de temps en temps le long de la plage,
mon ami pour le qui travaille pour la
division des ressources naturelles a attrapé
ce poisson vraiment bizarre et il
faisait peut-être un pied et demi de long et il
avait vraiment  de grandes dents presque la tête
ressemblait presque à un piranha
[Musique]
il savait ce que c'était que nous mais il a
dit que c'était un poisson préhistorique et
euh quand il l'a coupé et nettoyé
il a encore bougé pendant quelques heures
après qu'il  avait fait l'éviscération et
tout ce qui était
étranger
[Musique]
ce que je trouve intéressant à propos de Pepe la
description de Pepe est qu'il varie considérablement
qu'il y a des récits qui le
font paraître plus bien que ce soit un vieux
dinosaure le plésiosaure le long cou
comme vous le feriez  considérez le monstre du Loch Ness
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur la base des descriptions que les gens
nous ont appelées et nous ont fourni
euh nous pensons que Pepe mesure probablement 15 à 20
pieds de long
euh au moins une partie de lui ressemble à un serpent
il y a d'autres rapports de  il s'agit plus
d'un serpent géant ressemblant à un serpent de 30
à 40 pieds de long, puis il y en a
où il s'agit plus de plusieurs bosses de
tout ce qui est inconnu, une créature
inconnue, nous pensons qu'il a probablement un
corps plus épais
euh dans un long cou avec  la tête,
euh,
mais vous savez que c'est le mystère avec les
créatures aquatiques, c'est que vous ne pouvez pas
tout voir la plupart du temps, vous
n'en voyez qu'une partie, vous savez qu'ils sont
comme des icebergs, la plupart des observations de
sa couleur semblent indiquer  que c'est une
bête de type sombre qu'ils disent marron ou
noir ou vert foncé c'est toujours considéré
comme une créature de type sombre
étrangère
ou âgée de 16 ans
nous faisions du ski nautique juste au nord de la
ville
et
ma sœur était tombée de l'
eau  excuse
[Musique]
tu sais que tu te promènes et tu te balances
pour la prendre
et nous choisissons comme nous l'avons fait tu sais que
je suis sûr que nous étions en train de faire le tour et
tout ça et d'une manière ou d'une autre euh Chris le gars
avec qui nous étions et moi
toi  sais que nous ne faisions pas vraiment
attention à elle
et
elle a crié quelque chose je vous savez je
ne me souviens pas il y a 30 ans et
elle l'était et je l'ai regardée et vous savez que
ça a attiré mon attention la nuit
je suis comme quoi allons-nous  et ses yeux étaient
si grands
qu'elle était comme s'il y avait quelque chose dans l'
eau
juste ici
et j'ai dit de quoi tu parlais
et elle était catégorique sur le fait qu'elle voulait
sortir de l'eau elle avait peur
et elle s'est précipitée hors de l'eau
nous l'avons tirée  hors de l'eau assez
rapidement et elle n'a pas été dans l'
eau depuis ici au lac Pépin et
donc elle n'a pas nagé dans le lac depuis 30
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que nous avons appris, ce sont
les gens qui sont dans le  l'eau
et ils voient qu'ils ont ce qu'on appelle une
rencontre rapprochée avec Pepe ils ils
ça les secoue un peu
pendant un moment et ils veulent certainement
sortir de l'eau tout de suite et ils
ne sont pas trop impatients de retourner dans l'eau
dans un avenir proche, vous savez que
cela changera éventuellement, euh, mais ils sont un
peu nerveux au début et je
suppose que je peux en quelque sorte comprendre que si
à tout moment vous voyez quelque chose qui vous fait peur,
je veux dire que
je n'aime pas trop les serpents
moi-même  et si je te vois tout d'un coup serpenter à
un pied de moi, je saute généralement
en arrière et je suis à l'affût des serpents
après cela,
elle a dit que c'était un noir et qu'elle pouvait
distinguer une sorte de nageoire mais elle a dit
qu'elle  ne pouvait pas vraiment voir à quel point il était gros,
mais elle pouvait dire qu'il était assez
grand sous l'eau,
nous avons entendu des histoires selon lesquelles il y
avait de gros esturgeons qui vivaient dans ce lac,
vous savez, j'ai dit
poisson et elle non ce n'était pas un  poisson c'était
gros
et c'était effrayant
et vous savez à ce jour
nous n'en avons jamais vraiment beaucoup parlé
les gens en parlaient dans la région, mais
en dehors de la communauté, ce n'était pas
très connu il y a environ cinq ou six ans. Je
regardais en fait une émission à
la télévision sur la région du Loch Ness et
je me suis dit que ce ne serait pas bien de
obtenir un groupe de gens qui viennent ici et
essayer de découvrir ce qu'est Pepe
et euh quelle est la meilleure façon de le faire
quelle est la meilleure façon d'obtenir un certain intérêt
à découvrir ce qu'est Pepe et c'est
euh j'y ai pensé pendant un moment et
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai proposé que j'offre une
récompense à quiconque peut prouver l'
existence de Pepe et j'ai envoyé une
centaine de courriels à différents
organes de presse et médias d'information
que nous offrons une récompense de cinquante mille
dollars à quiconque peut
fournir la preuve de ce qu'est la liste de Pepe's Lake Pepin,
puis à partir de là, quelques
journaux l'ont repris euh des stations d'information
dans de nombreux médias nationaux ont commencé à le
reprendre nous sommes sur la National Public
Radio euh la dignité a augmenté de façon exponentielle à partir de
là nous avons commencé à recevoir des demandes de renseignements
du monde entier, j'étais en fait sur
la plus grande station de radio de Tokyo au Japon
pendant 20 minutes à parler de euh Pepe et le
gouvernement chinois a euh un site Web qui
parlait un peu de Pepe et j'ai
reçu des appels téléphoniques d'
Australie et de Suède et à peu près
chaque pays et chaque état autour des
gens sont vraiment très intéressés par
ce qui se passe ici sur le lac Pepin et bien
jetons la région des érables et vous
pouvez nous montrer que
nous examinerons certaines des zones les plus courantes
pour les observations et ensuite nous pourrons
choisir  où nous voulons être sûrs d'aller aujourd'hui,
faites-vous ces drapeaux orange euh ici sont
des observations que vous avez documentées ou est-
ce vrai Chad oui d'accord datant
des années 1860 jusqu'à ce que vous sachiez l'heure actuelle,
nous sommes ici en ce moment euh question de
fait où se trouve notre quai, il
s'appelle le point central parce qu'il est au
centre du lac Pepin, donc nous sommes
situés au centre ici euh au fur et à mesure que nous allons
en aval euh l'eau devient plus profonde de 85
à 100 pieds de profondeur par endroits ou nous l'un
des  les endroits préférés semblent être
entre Stockholm et made in rock Bluff
et Maiden Rock Bluff est euh pour une
raison quelconque semble avoir beaucoup d'observations
juste autour de cette zone, vous pouvez voir
que c'est fait dans le rock Wisconsin ouais
en arrière-plan ouais et euh et  plusieurs
autres sont dans le même voisinage, donc je
pense que nous voulons vraiment frapper cette
zone euh
et euh je pense que nous aurons de bons
succès ouais vous pouvez voir que nous serons
juste au point chaud ouais ouais je suis
excité allons-y  commencez ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre bateau euh c'est un bateau à roue à aubes de 129 passagers
c'est un authentique
bateau à roue de bataille il n'a pas d'
hélices ou de propulseurs c'est euh juste les
pagaies c'est ce qui le fait traverser l'
eau que nous faisons  des visites énergiques sur le
bateau
ou nous les emmenons spécifiquement, nous les appelons des
visites de surveillance énergiques, nous leur montrons les
zones historiques, les zones pittoresques et nous
parlons de Pepe et nous parlons
des récompenses et leur disons que tout le monde
garde ses appareils photo prêts parce que  non seulement
vous allez prendre des photos de tous ces
superbes paysages, mais vous pourriez
vous faire gagner cinquante mille dollars
[Musique] nous
arrivons ici à Marina
Point qui est euh là où se trouve la marina de Lake City,
c'est la plus grande marina du
Mississippi River et nous allons faire le tour de
ce point euh aller un peu en aval
puis nous allons traverser le lac
et monter euh en amont le long de la
côte du Wisconsin vers Maiden Rock et
voir si nous ne pouvons pas trouver Pepe
[Musique]
d'accord,
donc je pense que ce qui est intéressant, c'est que nous
parlons toujours du fait qu'il s'agit d'une seule
créature, mais en réalité, il peut y avoir
plusieurs de ces créatures, surtout s'il y
a eu des centaines d'années d'
observations, il peut y en avoir assez pour se
reproduire. J'ai toujours eu envie  il
doit y avoir un groupe ou ou plusieurs créatures
euh parce que je ne vois tout simplement pas que vous savez que les
observations remontent à des centaines d'années et
je ne vois pas comment une créature pourrait
être en vie aussi longtemps oui donc je pense qu'il y
a une petite communauté  d'entre eux
sont probablement assez grands, donc leur
taille réduit probablement le
nombre dans la communauté à un
certain degré parce que vous savez que nous
ne sommes pas l'océan avec une profondeur illimitée
et des endroits où aller, donc je pense que vous  'ai
raison, je pense qu'il doit y en avoir plus
d'un sur la base de nombreux rapports que j'ai
reçus selon lesquels, que la créature soit
inoffensive ou mignonne ou non, les gens
en avaient peur et bien sûr si vous
nagez dans l'eau ski nautique
canotage  et une grande bête de 30 à 40 pieds
selon certains, même 10 pieds vient
à côté de vous, cela va être
terrifiant, que ce soit un esturgeon,
que ce soit un poisson-chat géant, un
requin taureau ou une espèce inconnue,
nous savons qu'il n'y a aucun rapport à
ce sujet  jamais blessé quelqu'un en mordant la
jambe de quelqu'un ou euh
autre que nous avons un rapport que vous avez
trouvé de certaines personnes près d'Alma
où une créature a sauté hors de l'eau
à environ quatre pieds et a arraché un oiseau
en l'air et et c'est vraiment  le
seul
excitant que nous ayons où il se
nourrit de quoi que ce soit ouais j'avais parcouru
le monde à la recherche de ces monstres
et légendes et je n'avais jamais entendu parler d'une
récompense offerte pour leur capture,
donc c'est vraiment ce qui m'a tout
de suite intrigué pas nécessairement la récompense elle-même
mais le mystère qui l'entoure lui a donné
cette force que non
seulement il y avait des rapports à ce sujet, mais que
quelqu'un offrait une récompense pour trouver
la vérité derrière cela,
eh
bien, vous savez, j'entends de plusieurs
personnes différentes qui ont eu
des expéditions que
cela  ils sont intéressés par la récompense
mais je ne pense pas
que ce soit leur principale impulsion je pense qu'ils
ont le désir de résoudre des mystères oui et
et euh s'ils obtiennent une récompense pour le faire
c'est juste euh la cerise sur le gâteau ouais
ce qu'ils ont vraiment  vouloir est ici c'est un
mystère c'est documenté depuis des centaines d'
années ne
résolvons pas ce mystère tout le monde veut
résoudre un mystère
au journal Saint Paul Pioneer
Press parlant de Pepe et de la
récompense de cinquante mille dollars
offerte pour la preuve de l'existence de Pepe
[Musique]
eh bien, l'une des personnes de l'expédition
était un plongeur et il prévoyait de
descendre et de voir ce qu'il pourrait  voir
sous l'eau
Corey était un peu réticent à plonger dans
le lac Pepin et je me suis dit il y a longtemps que
je ne le ferais jamais j'ai fini par
surmonter la peur d'aller dans l'
eau sombre et trouble du Mississippi
quelque chose que j'avais eu peur de faire
depuis que nous étions enfants sur la
rivière
à partir du moment où nous avons quitté le débarcadère,
nous n'étions que sur le bateau, nous étions sur l'
eau pendant environ cinq minutes,
notre lecteur de sonar voyait quelque chose
d'inhabituel sur le graphique que
je n'ai jamais vu  tout ce qui est grand
bien c'est deux pieds
c'est deux pieds chaque pied donc 350. donc nous
voyions un cône de 50 pieds à cette profondeur
c'est toujours effrayant c'est
50 pieds je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais en
10 15 ans d'utilisation de ce graphique  Je n'ai
jamais rien vu d'approchant
parce que c'était à environ 25 pieds, nous étions à 36
pieds d'eau, il y avait 25 pieds de profondeur, je
pense que cela occupait environ les
deux tiers de l'écran, donc ça
devait être énorme
à ça  fois que j'ai mis mon équipement de plongée et que j'ai
travaillé le nerf, j'ai fait un
saut arrière dans l'eau
[Musique]
et c'était comme peut-être 10-15 minutes
dedans, j'étais en quelque sorte à l'aise, vous
savez, cette peur est partie et et
juste à  la fin là,
tout s'est en quelque sorte calmé
[Musique]
J'ai eu un sentiment qui m'a envahi comme juste
une sensation de picotement dans ma tête et dans mes
oreilles ou autre et c'était comme si j'étais
observé ou quelque chose comme
quelque chose là-bas regardait  moi
et à peu près à ce moment-là j'ai vu
quelque chose de très proche de moi en noir en
quelque sorte avait l'air lisse je ne l'ai jamais touché
ni je ne crois pas que ça m'a touché
je n'ai vu aucune sorte de nageoires ou de tête
ou  quelque chose comme ça, mais aussi vite que je l'ai
vu tout d'un coup, il a bougé et
je l'ai vu comme bouger et à gauche et il
m'a en quelque sorte jeté comme un tourbillon ou
ou une vague qui était vous savez de haut en
bas
et à droite  à ce moment-là, alors que je me faisais
jeter et que j'étais vraiment effrayé,
je l'ai vu c'est gros a décollé à la
surface vu où le boulon était mon
régulateur a volé hors de ma bouche
Quand Corey est sorti de l'eau, j'étais
inquiet pour lui,
il était évidemment  terrifiés et
nous ne savions pas ce qui s'était passé
et je criais pour que mon pote
me sorte de l'eau et c'était comme pour une
éternité  et il m'a finalement fait
monter dans le bateau
j'étais complètement épuisé tu sais qu'ils m'avaient
en quelque sorte demandé si j'allais bien tu
sais j'ai dit que j'allais bien mais que
ça s'est juste terminé là en ce qui concerne
mon
mon expérience  de cette
expérience.
être sur
l'eau et voir des esturgeons qui, vous le
savez, peuvent mesurer sept pieds de long jusqu'à 200
livres ils voient l'un des vous savez qu'ils
voient un gros poisson comme celui-là au-dessus de
l'eau ils vont dire oh mon Dieu
qu'est-ce que c'est  parce que c'est probablement
un poisson, il y a généralement toujours une
explication
et ce n'est pas un monstre, que ce soit une
bûche, que ce soit des vagues roulant sur
quelque chose ou une illusion d'optique, cela
pourrait être cela, mais vous savez la chose la plus
probable que ce serait, je suppose que ce
serait ça  serait un esturgeon
[Musique]
50 ou 60 espèces différentes de
poissons là-dedans, sans parler de toutes les espèces aviaires que vous connaissez
qui volent avec
des canards et des oies cygnes,
mais pour la plupart, il y en
a une énorme abondance, vous savez  la
faune aquatique et les motifs similaires et pour
revenir un peu plus loin lorsque nous avons
visualisé cette image pour la première fois
sur le sonar, ils sont notre détecteur de profondeur,
vous pouvez juger de la taille approximative
par les blips que nous les appelons sur ces sonars
bien cette image particulière que nous  'ai
vu là-bas, nous devinions n'importe où
de six à huit pieds de large comme vous le
savez, 26 27 pieds environ à environ 35 pieds de
long
est énorme et je crois honnêtement que
j'étais j'ai eu une rencontre avec le monstre énergique
nous savons qu'il y a  énorme énorme poisson dans
le lac,
il a été signalé qu'il y avait du poisson dans le
lac de plus de 100 livres de poisson-chat de plus de 100
livres et cela pourrait peut-être causer
une certaine confusion
que peut-être le Pepe n'est qu'un énorme
poisson qui n'a jamais été un esturgeon qui a été
retiré de  le lac, il y a eu des
requins taureaux qui ont été trouvés dans le
lac, nous avons donc toutes ces espèces d'
animaux et de poissons dans le lac qu'ils voient peut-être que
peut-être que les gens
identifient mal ces créatures et si
vous nagez dans un 10 pieds 120  livre des
pinceaux d'esturgeon par vous, cela va
vous sembler être un serpent de mer
[Musique]
d'accord,
je suppose qu'il est possible
qu'il puisse s'agir d'une nouvelle espèce de poisson, mais
encore une fois, ce serait très peu probable
étant donné notre ministère des
Ressources naturelles et le  Les filets maillants et les filets de test
qu'ils font dans tous les systèmes fluviaux et
lacustres du Minnesota, nous allons
remarquer qu'en entrant, vous savez, parce que
notre DNR est constamment à la recherche d'
espèces envahissantes que nous avons ici comme
la carpe volante et les moules zébrées et
tout ça donc la quantité de surveillance
que nous faisons vous savez de nos
cours d'eau s'il ne va pas y avoir un nouveau
poisson vous savez et s'il y en a nous
allons le savoir tout de suite
[Musique]
vous savez aussi loin que  combien de personnes
croient ou ne croient pas,
je ne sais pas quel serait ce nombre, je
dirais que c'est
aussi loin que les croyants vont, c'est probablement un
assez petit nombre
de personnes qui croient réellement qu'il y
a quelque chose là-bas.
monde à
la recherche de folklore et de légendes parlant
avec des témoins fouillant dans d'anciennes
archives historiques, puis
se rendant réellement aux endroits où ces légendes
se produisent et essayant de trier les faits des
hôtels de fiction
et les deux expéditions, nous avions beaucoup d'
équipement, nous avions des caméras sous-marines sonar que
nous avions  audio vidéo nous
pêchions, nous avions des filets nous-mêmes comme appâts
là-dedans et nous n'avons trouvé
aucune preuve du monstre, mais ce qui
nous a intrigués, c'est que lorsque nous
passions à côté de gens qui pêchaient, nous
appelions simplement et voyons s'ils avaient
jamais vu Pepe ou s'ils avaient été à
l'affût et même si beaucoup d'entre eux
n'avaient pas eu d'observation, ce qui nous a
étonnés, c'est que beaucoup de ces pêcheurs et
femmes dont nous ne pensions même pas qu'ils
croiraient en un monstre ont dit qu'ils gardaient un
appareil photo avec eux juste au cas où
[Musique]
J'ai vu plusieurs photos de ce que
les gens croient être Pepe
et bien sûr on dirait que ça pourrait être une
sorte de monstre du Loch Ness mais
vous regardez ces choses et vous
dites aussi que vous savez quoi  cela pourrait être une bûche
vous savez qui flotte sur la rivière
au bon moment l'ondulation
qui est là vous pourriez avoir des vagues
passant au-dessus de quelque chose alors oui je
veux dire peut-il avoir l'air vous pouvez faire
ressembler n'importe quoi je veux dire je pourrais  prenez
deux hot-dogs et collez-les dans l'eau
et potentiellement faites-le ressembler à un
monstre du lac si je voulais parfois les
images que nous voyons
bien il y a ce truc dernier cri
appelé Photoshop je ne sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler
mais euh c'est  incroyable les choses qu'ils
peuvent faire avec Photoshop ces jours-ci maintenant
qui n'existaient pas il y a 30 ans et il y a
ces vieilles photos là-bas que euh je
ne sais pas comment vous simulez quelque chose qui
a l'air long et maigre nageant dans
l'eau ainsi et  alors nous devons aussi
regarder, vous savez, regardez la société en ce
moment, nous courons tous avec des
téléphones portables, nous courons tous, vous savez,
attachés à la hanche à nos
téléphones avec appareil photo, si quelque chose comme ça est
là-bas, nous sommes  va avoir de très
bonnes photographies, vous savez la preuve que
[la musique]
est
avant la récompense
euh
il n'y avait pas il
n'y avait pas de référentiel pour que les gens
disent que j'ai une observation tu verrais
quelque chose sur le lac et  vous ne
pouviez rien faire
avec,
euh, donc
c'est en partie pourquoi nous avons créé le
site Web avec la récompense, c'est que nous
supposons que maintenant les gens vont dire que nous
avons vu quelque chose, alors maintenant ils ont un endroit où
ils peuvent le signaler  à et nous pouvons commencer à
être une bibliothèque de ces observations que les
citoyens locaux ont commentées bien sûr, comme
tout le reste, vous avez vos
opposants ou quoi que ce soit, vous savez que certaines
personnes disent hé Larry essaie de se faire un
nom mais après avoir travaillé avec
Larry,
il voulait  créer un attrait touristique pour
amener les gens dans une région parce que nous avons
une fois qu'ils sont ici c'est une très belle
région je doute que Pepe ait été créé
juste pour attirer les touristes
euh c'est une possibilité que
ce Pepe ait été
remanufacturé de temps en
temps  retour mais je pense et il y avait
au départ il y avait il y avait un Mystique
ou une ou des créatures mystérieuses mystérieuses
dans le lac je pense que Larry euh
a rajeuni le monstre que ces
histoires circulent depuis
des centaines d'années mais encore une fois elles ont été
presque oubliées et Larry vient
les a simplement sortis des livres d'histoire
et les a rendus à nouveau pertinents.
donc je voulais
venir à Lake City et voir de quoi il s'agissait
et sortir et regarder le
lac et
donc si c'est si ça fait tourner les affaires à
cet égard,
alors ça fait son travail je suppose mais je
pense que Larry non seulement  profite des
touristes, mais il prétend toujours
qu'il n'y a pas de mal à promouvoir
votre histoire que si vous venez ici,
que vous voyiez ou non Pepe dans le lac,
vous passerez un bon moment
et une région magnifique, donc je pense qu'il est
juste  promouvoir l'histoire unique de la ville
étrangère
[Musique]
nous avons 13 variétés que nous brassons dans notre
brasserie dans notre brasserie est à propos de
ce que nous appelons une brasserie à six barils,
ce qui signifie que nous fabriquons environ 186 gallons
par semaine,
nous en avons plusieurs  nos propres styles que
nous servons, allant d'une bière plus légère
à une stout plus foncée, toutes nos bières
sont censées refléter quelque chose
qui fait de l'aile rouge ce qu'elle est et et
la région du lac Pépin ce que nous
essayons et
promouvons des histoires qui  sont uniques à cette
région et Pepe's Porter est
[Musique]
notre bière Porter qui est une euh que nous
brassons en tant qu'American Porter est une bière plus foncée
et nous avons décidé de lui donner le nom du
monstre du lac local
et il y a eu une tradition à propos de Pepe le
lac  monstre aussi longtemps que tout le monde peut s'en
souvenir, il y
a donc des coupures de journaux que
vous trouverez au fil des ans,
des queues qui ont été racontées puis
transmises à propos de Pepe le monstre du lac
à nouveau, tout joue dans les légendes et
vous savez ce qui est vrai et quoi  cela ne
dépend pas de la personne qui l'a vécu
[Musique]
merci
créature étrangère [Musique] les cartes postales et tous les
souvenirs
Pepe est un monstre amusant pour la plupart des gens de
la communauté les enfants de la
communauté ont
l'air énergiques et rient et rigolent  et
parlons de Pepe aujourd'hui nous le décrivons comme
un monstre adapté aux enfants nous disons aux
enfants qu'il est timide c'est pourquoi vous ne
le voyez jamais parce qu'il est timide [
Musique]
les t-shirts et sweat-shirts que nous
portons sont tous imprimés ou brodés
par des entreprises locales qui  faire ce genre de
travail,
puis les petits chiots en peluche
sont fabriqués par une arrière-grand-mère qui
vit ici à Lake City
Evelyn est une arrière-grand-mère et elle
a l'autorisation de
Larry Nielsen pour les faire et ils sont
tous fabriqués par  main, elle achète le tissu et le
découpe et brode les yeux
et euh des trucs et elle a dit que le rembourrage
est la partie la plus difficile
[Musique]
technique
après l'expédition J'ai filmé quelques
entretiens de suivi avec certains des
autres membres de l'équipage  et le projet est
toujours en cours, j'ai dû le mettre en
veilleuse pendant un certain temps en raison d'
autres projets qui ont surgi,
je le crois,
ma conviction est que ce poisson ou ce mammifère en
particulier est un solo à
lui tout seul ma croyance
et  la raison pour laquelle je dis cela est que s'il y
en avait plus, je pense que vous verriez
plus d'observations, il y aurait
plus de connaissances à leur sujet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec l'avènement de Pepe, cela a mis Lake City
une carte  est devenu au
lieu d'une attraction locale, nous sommes devenus
une attraction nationale et internationale
car, selon M. Nielsen, il
reçoit des visiteurs de divers pays
d'Europe et d'Asie qui
viennent spécifiquement dans ce lac pour trouver
Pepe chaque fois qu'il y a une observation de
quelque chose comme Pepe le lac  monstre il y
a toujours un boom pour vous savez n'importe quelle
localité où c'est et et c'est
génial pour la ville
euh vous savez je pense qu'il est probable qu'il
y ait réellement un monstre
qui existe je ne pense pas que ce soit probable
mais vous savez quoi non  on peut dire avec
certitude parce que personne n'a trouvé cette
chose échouée sur le rivage, vous savez que personne ne
l'a eue, vous savez, montez et prenez un
fil d'Ariane de votre main et je suis
certain qu'il y a des gens là-bas qui
croient vraiment qu'ils ont vu  ceci et si
c'est ce qu'ils croient bien et et
si d'autres personnes veulent venir tenter leur
chance à Lake City pour essayer de
voir s'ils peuvent trouver Pepe très bien
pour toutes les personnes impliquées, nous savons pertinemment
que les gens viennent en ville juste  voir le
ou espérer une opportunité ou
une possibilité de voir que le monstre ou le
peppy je crois que dans l'ensemble je dirais que la
communauté embrasse Pepe comme notre
mascotte
je pense que les gens quand nous avons commencé à parler
de Pepe et avons offert à notre Office du tourisme
offert la récompense  cela a rappelé
aux gens que le lac Pépin est un bel
endroit à visiter et que nous étions
ici, donc cela a donné à notre ville et à notre lac
et à toute notre région une
certaine publicité le but d'être amical
aujourd'hui est plus accueillant que c'est
plus un  attirer les touristes c'est plus amusant pour les
familles vous pouvez aller au lac Pepin vous
pouvez faire du ski nautique vous
pouvez profiter du cadre magnifique et
peut-être aussi attraper ce mignon petit animal
donc nous sommes en train de travailler
quelque chose d'ennuyeux M. Nielsen sera
probablement  choisis un mois plein d'entrain ou un jour plein d'entrain
et si je devais choisir un jour plein d'entrain
ce serait ce jour d'avril 1871 quand les
deux pêcheurs les découvrirent
[Musique]
en ligne [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]